[Musique]
ce n'est pas parce qu'on a élu domicile
dans un quartier ou dans une ville que
l'on est tous pareils on a tous un
voisin honni voisine qui pensent
complètement différemment en général au
québec n'y a pas de grandes fractures
idéologiques mais il ya toujours des
exceptions à la règle des
circonscriptions où la polarisation et
marquer notamment sur les questions
socio-économiques en tête de lice c'est
henri sainte anne
verdun et pontiac ce sont des
circonscriptions où vient le grand mix
social c'est henri 50 par exemple une
partie du territoire et au centre ville
et l'autre portion est dense et henri un
endroit un peu plus pauvres la même
chose avec verdun et ce sont deux
circonscriptions où il ya de plus en
plus d'embourgeoisement que une
conscience que cette nation ce
territoire fait partie de notre identité
et que donc diriger la nation c'est
diriger des gens qui sont sur l'ensemble
du territoire et dans la circonscription
de frontières le sud près d'ottawa ya
donc beaucoup fonctionnaires qui gagnent
des salaires plus élevés que ceux qui
habitent dans la portion rural de la
circonscription jean planer encore plus
loin ensemble pour relever les défis de
demain
il faut s'unir postis visez donc ça
souvent réduits à des étiquettes bégué
kaki libéral solidaire aujourd'hui ces
étiquettes ne veulent pas grand chose
les gouvernants peuvent aussi se
manifester sur les questions
identitaires dans des circonscriptions
comme robert baldwin pourrissement de
saint louis et notre dame de grâce là on
le retrouve une forte population
anglophone qui se démarque des
répondants francophones mois des
rencontres et des québécois québécoise
entre autres d'origine haïtienne mais
des québécois à part entière on a des
tendances
la première il ya très peu de
polarisation dans les circonscriptions
détenues par le parti québécois
ce sont souvent des circonscriptions en
région un peu plus homogène soussou
économiquement parlant
autre tendance il ya un fort consensus
sur les questions identitaires dans les
circonscriptions caquistes les
informations présentées dans ce
reportage repose sur les réponses de
175000 65 répondants ayant participé à
la boussole électorale entre le 13
septembre et le 24 septembre 2018